these organisms are members of the
phylum bryozoa a name that translates in
Greek to Moss animals bryozoa are
notable in the animal kingdom because of
just how Colonial the phyla is the
individual bryozoa called a zooid
navigates the waters as a larva
eventually attaching itself to some kind
of solid surface and from there it will
begin to divide butting off but keeping
its descendants close and connected as
they increase in Number the arrangement
of the zuoids dictates the shape of
their colony as does the material they
secrete to support the colony overall
some excrete a gelatinous material
others rely on chitinous materials that
give them more rigidity